[Music]
the lives of our favorite Disney
Princess has changed forever when they
were teenagers but we were curious to
know what happened when they were kids
and toddlers before meeting their prince
charming this is why we imagined what
their lives would be like if this is
your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as kids Snow White she's the
first Disney Princess and also the
youngest and only 14 years old her
childhood is not too far behind her Snow
White was born to a royal family
unfortunately she didn't have the chance
to live the life of a princess her
mother passed away after birth only
living long enough to give her that
beautiful name then her father remarried
a cold-hearted Queen only to join Snow
White's mother shortly after the Evil
Queen cared about nothing other than
being the fairest of them all and when
she saw that the little girl was
becoming more beautiful every day she
became jealous this is why she dressed
the childhood rags and forced her to
work as a maid so when we saw how an
artist reimagined Snow White wearing
that beautiful dress we understand why
the Evil Queen was afraid of the
competition the princess is prettier
than ever and we think that she should
already be the fairest of them all even
at a very young age she's also wearing
the tiara that she deserves and seems to
be going outside for a picnic instead of
doing chores
maybe this is what Snow White would look
like if she had been raised by her
parents but everything happens for a
reason
so this life of misery might just be
what she had to go through to meet the
prince and live happily ever after
Cinderella here is another princess who
was treated like a servant this time
until she was 19 years old Cinderella
was born to wealthy parents who loved
her and lived in a beautiful castle her
life changed when her mother passed away
and her father remarried another woman
to make sure her daughter had a mother
figure in her life the young girl would
have been happier with a single father
because her stepmother turned out to be
a horrible woman when her father passed
away Cinderella was left alone this is
when she realized how cruel she could be
Lady Tremaine spoiled her two daughters
Anastasia and Drizella and forced the
young orphan to work as a slave no
matter what Cinderella had the strength
to stay sweet humble and kind but what
if this stepmother decided to treat her
like her own daughter instead this is
how the artists reimagined her she
doesn't need the help of mice or a fairy
godmother anymore
the young girl is already wearing a
gorgeous dress that she received for her
birthday and she's also wearing a tiara
herself because even if she's not a
princess yet she thinks that she
deserves to be treated like one
and she's right every child should be
the most important thing in the world to
their parents if you want to watch just
one more video the premium is the
platform where you should go get early
access to videos from the things the
taco the trendy the richest and many
other great channels in one place with
ad free browsing click this link to sign
up for the premium and get ready to
binge watch videos from your favorite
channels Aurora
her story is similar to what snow white
lid falling in a deep sleep and being
saved by defense of a prince but these
two princesses had really different
childhoods a king and a queen had been
blessed by a beautiful blonde daughter
people from all around the kingdom came
to celebrate her birth three of them
were fairies giving her the gift of
beauty and the gift of singing but
before the third period could use her
magic wand Maleficent appeared and
cursed young princess her life would end
when she would prick her finger on a
spinning wheel
the third fair used the last gift to
give Aurora the chance to be saved by
the Prince to make sure that she was
safe
the young blond girl was raised by the
three fairies until she was 16 years old
and as we can see from this picture they
took good care of her younger bra is
full of energy she's not the kind of kid
who will be able to sleep too early as
we can see the fairies finally decided
that she would be wearing a pink dress
but we bet that they will change their
mind soon and argue to make the princess
laugh this little family is proof that
even if your parents don't have the
chance to see you grow up what matters
most is that you can stay with people
who love you Ariel this beautiful sea
creature lived a childhood unlike any
other until she decided to live on land
at the age of 16 the Little Mermaid was
the seventh and youngest daughter of
King Triton ruler of Atlantica she
seemed to have all the things she needed
but this wasn't enough for her all her
life she collected little treasures that
belonged to humans and dreamed one day
walking on the land she spent her day
exploring the sea looking for another
object that sunk under the water
unfortunately this admiration for the
human world was not appreciated so she
had to keep it secret from other secrets
sebastien and flounder were the only
ones who knew about this as we can see
they have been friends for a very long
time
the yellow and blue fish was already by
her side when she was a little mermaid
Arielle seems to be a funny kid we bet
that she spends all day discovering new
places and finding objects that would
help her understand our world
her father is probably nervous every
time she leaves because he doesn't know
when she'll come back and we understand
why he is she's the kind of girl who can
exchange her voice for a pair of legs
and almost disappear forever
for a stranger we better watch this
little girl or teenage Ariel will get
into trouble really quickly Belle the
young woman is one of the lucky
princesses who had the chance to live a
beautiful child until her life changed
at age 17 her mother came from a wealthy
family but passed away shortly after the
birth of her daughter and Maurice was
left with the most precious thing he
could ever find so she had the chance to
be raised by a loving father and she
probably had a lot of unusual toys to
play with when we see all the crazy
things he can create but what she loved
most was reading as soon as she learned
how to read Belle couldn't keep herself
from opening a new book and being
transported into a new universe in this
picture you can see fell wearing her
most beautiful dress this is not the
girl we saw at the beginning of the
movie but the one that Morey saw in her
his princess she means the world to him
little Belle is not interested in any
boy because her father is the most
important thing in her life he is the
one who encourages her to follow her
dreams and he knows that women were born
to be more than just a pretty face
they are both a little weird but also
very smart and this is why they have an
amazing relationship jasmine she seems
to be one of the most fortunate
princesses on our list but her life was
not as beautiful as it seems Aladdin the
street urchin was envious of her
luxurious life but there was one thing
missing for her to be happy
as the daughter of the Sultan Jasmine
had to live in the palace she didn't
have the right to leave her royal home
or meet other people her mother passed
away years ago and the only friend that
she was left with was her pet tiger
Rajah
the princess thought it was a gift from
her mother as she used to tell her
stories of the tiger star Jasmine wanted
to see the world and experience life
outside so we think it was probably
difficult for her to live on her
as a child and this artist reimagined
her as a dreamer who can't wait to go
outside even if her father gives her all
the things she needs this is not with
little Jasmine once she just wants to do
what all the other kids do but no matter
what we know that her father the Sultan
loves her very much he just doesn't have
the time to show it the only thing
missing is the magic in your eyes
and Aladdin will one day make her
discover a whole new world Mulan
this girl is not a princess like any
other actually she isn't even one but
she has all the qualities she needs to
rule the world and become a queen even
if she's just 16 years old born and
raised in China
Mulan had to respect a lot of traditions
she was told that the girls must be
pretty be graceful and know how to serve
tea they are not supposed to fight they
said her family wanted to turn her into
the perfect housewife waiting for the
day she would meet her future husband
but this is not what clumsy and
free-spirited Mulan wanted when we see
how Irene martini reimagined her we know
that her dreams actually are bigger than
that this girl knows that being a kid is
about having fun and experimenting and
she doesn't want to play with dolls she
wants to play outside even if it means
getting dirty in the mud and ruining her
beautiful dress she is not shy to say
that she is one of the boys anyway she
never thought that wearing girls clothes
was comfortable as a kid she is not shy
to be herself but she could get prepared
for all the challenges waiting for her
in the future
daring is her biggest strength so make
sure that you don't stand in the way of
this stubborn kid who knows what she
wants and how to get it Tiana the more
we watch Disney Princess movies the more
we wanted to hear about their childhoods
this is why Tiana was one of the first
young women that we really got the
chance to see as a kid with her best
friend Charlotte she listened to the
classic tale of a princess kissing a
frog and she was disgusting Tiana was
not interested in boys but in learning
new things with her father James is the
one who taught her how to cook while
they were making their favorite recipes
they dreamed of opening a restaurant
together but you reminded her that she
had to work hard and when he passed away
19 year old Tiana never let go of her
dream this princess reimagined by an
artist doesn't know yet what it's like
to have tons of responsibilities this
little dreamer still has a lot of energy
wishing can only get her halfway to her
dream and this is what she's working on
right now little Tiana doesn't know
what's going to happen to her father now
but he will be forever estores
of inspiration for her Merida we know
what it's like to become a teenager and
get more distant with our parents Merida
is no exception when she was a kid she
had a close relationship with her father
and mother always ready to have fun she
would play hide-and-seek with the woman
who raised her but what she loved most
was archery we wouldn't let a child play
with a bow and arrow but this one is
extremely skilled the redhead was also
really curious and naive believing the
myths and legends of her kingdom little
did she know she would soon become the
hero of her own fairy tale story the
little Merida reimagined by Irene
martini is still very affectionate she
loves to cuddle with her bear which
could represent the relationship she had
with her mother at the time this little
girl is not really stubborn yet because
her parents let her do whatever she
wants
she doesn't have to think about looking
like a proper lady and everything is
perfect like that we hope she enjoys her
childhood as much as she can because she
will soon have to face the
responsibilities of being an adult we
think that 16 year old Merida we know is
still close to her inner child because
she acts like one and there's nothing
wrong with that
don't you think these little humans
often look much happier than grown-ups
Rapunzel we won't forget about the
princess who had a really unusual
childhood before her birth her mother
was sick and had to eat a magic golden
flower with healing properties this is
how Rapunzel got her powers but Mother
Gothel wanted it to be hers
when she saw she couldn't just cut the
blonde hair she decided to take the baby
instead this evil witch locked the child
in the tower until her 16th birthday
but even when she was on her own
Rapunzel was never alone
she had her friend Pascal to make her
laugh and her creativity to transform
her room into another universe we can
see her energy shine when we take a look
at the princess reimagined by an artist
she learned to be happy with little
things and can turn anything into a
funny activity her hair is not long
enough for her to jump out of the tower
but she is preparing herself for this
crazy adventure by dreaming out loud
painting and reading are great ways to
escape and this time this is certainly
something we can relate to is there any
princess who looks like you as a kid
don't be shy to tell us in the comment
section below we'd love to hear what you
think
and that's it virt in disney princesses
reimagined as kids if you want to see
more stories like this don't forget to
watch 10 Disney Princesses reimagined as
teenagers thanks for watching
[Music]